you grew up in Somalia and Yemen is that  right yes who was your favorite actor  growing up when you were living in those  countries John Klatt find out is that  true really coincidence he really was it  was not a coincidence and you just met  him backstage met him right now for the  first time so you were watching  jean-claude van Damme when you were a  kid mhm and it's so surreal now that  you're here oscar-nominated actor and  you pass him he's the firt you know you  see I did you see him in the hall and  you're like yeah I'm up next I'll see  you later Jean Claude I just think  that's a beautiful thing about the world  I think it's absolutely amazing it's  it's a blessing thank you okay in in do  you think you'd ever be in a film where  you would fight him would you like to  fight you're talking one time okay I  don't think do you want to do some  stretches yeah don't do it  you